did you meet any of the royal family
over there guess putting a lot of time
in London and of God they know they love
friends so they must know you over there
yeah yeah I went to this like exhibition
polo match one time and the princes were
there and they were playing and
afterward there was like a big line for
everyone that was there and you know
polos like a big I had never been to a
polo we don't really do we have polo
here yes some polo here I've never seen
it play off Lauren has a thing right
that's I think that's a Cologne yeah
yeah that's about that's about how much
I know about polos but I went to this
thing you get invited by the Royals you
go so and then there's like a big line
to go and meet them afterwards so I went
and I got in line and met the the
princes which ones both of them William
and Harry would okay all right and
they're all they want to know is when is
the friends reunion probably wanted to
know would you tell them
[Applause]
that's why we're at war with England
then actually I was in a I was in a bar
one time and Harry was there and I
actually ended up sitting at the same
table with him he said he's a lot of fun
really yeah Prince Harry so I've heard
he's a lot of fun you get the sense that
that guy knows how to enjoy yeah yeah a
lot of fun you redheaded geyser blasts
you